sickle there are there are a few things
in our world
that combine to make something greater
than what they are alone things that if
they didn't exist like someone is
someone combined peanut butter and
chocolate
and blew everyone's balls off right
those two yeah creamsicle ain't no
peanut butter and chocolate you don't
think that you're nuts a delightful
orange sherbet nope combined with a
creamy vanilla ice cream even the
texture when you when you bite the
creamsicle the outer orange layer almost
acts as a shell it slightly has a little
bit of a crisp or um original to it
where it breaks almost like in pieces of
like the creamsicles the messiest of all
pops bomb pop it's messier than the
creamsicle it's not the bomb Bob has the
qualities of every popsicle that existed
however you you unwrap the bomb the
creamsicle it's Mission imp Mission
Impossible you might as well hear the
theme song racing against the clock
before that thing melts